hey everybody what's going on play here
welcome to Monday melee we're here with
our special guest this week Jon Gabrus
John thank you for coming please thank
you so much for having mom and as always
you got Steve another one two twos Beth
in the chatroom creeper Jason O'Malley
in the corner John you may know him from
wildin out amazing joking off yeah Mike
I'm the one white guy on both of those
and also guy code youtube' thank you for
coming oh thank you so excited to
finally have people watch me play this
is like my Monday mornings but now with
now with the camera well a camera that
broadcast this is a good combination of
my like love of video games and raging
I'm gonna play games why don't you
[ __ ] guys today we will be playing
FIFA 15 and here's the thing I don't
know anything about soccer John you do
know sit yours I know a little bit about
soccer I don't I don't know I consider
myself not to know anything but upon
talking to bleh for five minutes I now
think I know I don't even know I thought
this is Paul Bettany I thought this guy
was like what why is Paul Bettany on the
front why is vision spoiler yeah you see
spoiler before everybody dies spoiler
but yeah so we're gonna play a little
FIFA 15 and again I know nothing I do
know those soccer is incredibly
complicated so every like country has
their own has a bunch of teams okay yeah
that's a soccer is actually one of the
least complicated sports really but what
you're saying like the division of right
yeah of course cuz this is horrifying
what's happening here I don't know
there's all these freaking country
okay well I'm Jojen and we were talking
about last names Gabrus and Blair time
flared intelligent okay well I'm
American yeah I'll go with see if I I'll
play as Italy
exactly it's kind of like good Jim okay
fair enough
but we were talking about pizza rolls
earlier yeah and America invented the
pizza roll but yeah Italy maybe I'm
gonna go Italy invading the pizza rolls
like saying that Asia the best thing the
agents ever did was general so no I this
is gonna horrify soccer fans but I just
like the logo of this but I feel like
there's kind of some kind
like science thing going on there like
atomic yeah Adam yeah yeah I think the
soccer ball at that point is considered
a proton Wow very good there we go in an
isotope
then Belgian isotopes I'll be playing
all right it's right I'll play as United
States not a major league soccer team
I'll just play as the US okay fair
enough the people are saying I'm used
international teams saltpans Heskey Froy
I think this is international well yeah
but I think because you're down there
[ __ ] around I would go up to the top
and must be Belgium oh I see okay
oh okay so don't so don't pick like I
think below that is like you're picking
amongst Belgian team you already know
way more about this game that I do well
that's just standard video game yeah
okay alright so I leave our uniforms
this is my favorite part of the game
right now I look at it all white I'm not
gonna lie I wish you did just the short
length I want to see some more thymio
yeah exactly
this is the money area yeah yeah I mean
I can't I can't perfect yeah I checked I
watched one clip and I was like oh yeah
maybe I shouldn't wear shorts since I
have giant white thighs no I mean that's
exactly why you should yeah I know I
know where my bread is buttered yeah get
all the bear chasers to twitch Oh sweets
I think we still accidentally didn't
choose national teams wait they said
yeah we didn't do it all right
well as long as we both didn't do it and
we're not playing like the Belgian
national team versus the Seattle
Sounders right exactly
uh okay okay well should we go back and
try to pick the national team yeah let's
go back to try to do that we're gonna
try it for whoever it all these people
are so wait hot so how does that work
wait maybe the way it's got to be here
scanning but it's Shiva Chicago fire
okay now these are the amazing teams
okay these are the
okay I can't choose oh geez nope okay
I'm in United States but I cannot choose
the division for some reason I don't
know yeah it just says pro league for me
oh I see so oh we have to find the net
oh here we go International oh here we
go choice Oh got it
all right and your team oh yes this
makes so much more sense rest of world
is that what I want wrestlers like you
know what screw it put him in the
rest'll international you picked a very
specific Belgian team and I picked a
very specific America now we're back us
alright now we're in it here we here we
go here we go and uniforms margin only
marginally better unlock this oh god
damn it yeah hold on yes okay here we go
all right I'm going away look pretty
good hey shoulder this guy's got good
shoulders yeah as I choose my soccer
players based on the one body part they
don't use yeah that's got great fingers
all right oh this looks good to me yeah
I just had a realization that we are
recording this I got so into the game
all right let's
I'm ready Clint Dempsey wait wait uh
Madden I thought is what gave us comedy
bang bang episode future you stuff for
Biglia and Victor tiny is one of the
funniest things I've ever heard
yeah Birbiglia is of course a hilarious
dude and the voice of victor tiny was
Victor slash tiny is the Brendan who's
now Brendon small Brendon small
Metalocalypse he played these two
characters it's just so goddamn oh man
and and home movies right oh yeah and
then he's an amazing guitar player so
yeah and he's got a monthly show with
the baked potato it's supposed to be
really good so yeah yeah maybe so much
oh yeah that's not that's a comedy bang
bang episode I forgot which episode it
is but you could search it on yes so
okay we've got referee eNOS Bell BAE
that's good he knew his ball
one name exactly all right I don't know
yes this is oh wait what is this I think
your training oh wait why am i training
let's get out of here Oh press options
button to play oh here we go
yes oh okay that was just a mini game
here we go well right friends some dude
asked am I the only English I don't know
where we play every plate looks like
we're playing in Belgium yeah or at
least that might be a visitor section
based on the 12 foot high chain-link
fence I actually just went to a
international friendly match in Spain
and I was super excited about it but
then you get there and they don't serve
alcohol international matches because
people are too dangerous but I was
really stoked we got like we were in the
second row on oh my god right did you
see unique like crazy highlights it was
like it was a high-scoring game I think
was for two that at the end of the match
which was pretty exciting but mostly we
were like a Caitlyn kink and alcohol
here but luckily it was answer damn so
we were able to find a way ah perfect
jeez that is a big fence good lord
yeah this is like enter the Octagon yeah
sorry I accidentally had a reflex skip
the [ __ ] cutscenes don't care all
right so we're not gonna okay X I don't
know I don't know that I had never
played this so I think oh there we go
next I hit I hit a square oh [ __ ] luck
just passed it in yet so X is past
X is past Syria we think box is maybe
steel I think yeah just say box yeah do
you say square
I say square but it's a box all right
all right
oh wait wait what do we just say box was
I think we said X is definitely past
and oh man you're already so good but I
don't know what I'm doing to be honest
all right here we go I'm just I like to
I like good ball movement I like I like
passing it around up there easily easily
picked up I just slide up
I don't think box is shoot yeah oh it's
new but you know what by the enemy No
did you nice that was circle you say
circle or do you say I say portal to
another I don't know why I say box as
you always said box I think I have yeah
what do you say for the try you say
triangle yeah Box triangle circle I got
access to the perfect lr1 one joystick
deeper cross box cross ice box box seems
to be slide the guys in black or hate
yet there we go all my guys are on the
ground do the slide tackles I think no
all right circle is kick it over the
bowl Kulina it's a circle maybe is
across certainly yes signal must be
across okay and that's how squares
tackle somebody said oh is shoot
somebody says cubicle got his bats
I guess triangle equals pyramid yeah
I'll pyramid there you go nice
get in there
Oh rats wife my own advantage USA but
look at that clean it was clean get it
up there
tiny I passed it to you all right come
on this way
I do liable wait how do i sprint I don't
know I just say I bet it's one of these
up here
is their button just a foul so you need
yeah it was just like punch which is
punch Oh what button do you wear you act
like you hurt for ways to off sides l1
and squares cross ball is life the guest
reminds me of our deal and Illuminati
this is our master botanist
here we go Circle eschewed squares
tackle triangle as through past X's past
right stick is skill or a trigger is the
skills probably start doing some jazzy
[ __ ] oh yeah oh there we go do some
jazzy [ __ ] let's pause alright come on
take this take this sprint sprint get in
there first shot near uncle
no one has either near me Illuminati is
confirmed Illuminati confirmed
correct daddy I like how you guys read
the chat yeah why else would we make you
guys chat well that's the whole point of
Monday melee here we go okay boy there's
some kind of power thing I think that's
happens right here we go I'm Sturgis
jazzy [ __ ] why am i doing why did I do
that this is good I know you guys think
is this hilarious now but like in about
20 minutes are gonna be like just passed
the ball what's your problem
why are you to get these I go I'm having
so much fun with these new yet this is
absolutely frustrating for even me yeah
I'm actually getting the play at the
watches Clint Dempsey Dempsey oh wow
here we go
indirect no no no let's get heated take
that name Geelong Vincent Kompany
PK yellow coach just playing yeah
I need you to apologize for calling a
square uh looks like oh man he's his own
man let him do what he wants all squares
or boxes not all boxes are squares max
do the tap is it dirty right back how do
you shoot a circle somebody once said
that rugby is what a gentleman sport no
it's a rugby's of gentleman sport played
by hooligans and soccer is a hooligan
sport played by gentle interesting it's
actually the vice-versa place for its
Ock so rugby is played by a gentleman
but it's a tough sport this sport is a
gentlemanly sport but the people play it
our monster who's the guy was grabbing
everyone's joke all the time yeah or
just many people yeah that's just a
soccer thing I I don't know if you
brought this up because I played rugby
or did you just up oh no I forgot to
tell ya I didn't
I played rugby for four years in
university in college and for the last
couple of years I played in the New York
City for frontier oh my god every men's
to wait so I'm some rugby questions the
girls the scrum right that's how it
starts
yeah they drop the ball in and then it
gets kicked out why do people give up
the ball when they like to have to give
up the ball when you get knocked down
yes you're not maintaining possession
ball once on the ground so you have to
give it up but you try to give it to
your friend and try to put it behind you
so that when a ruck is formed which is
two people pushing over a tackled body
or the ball free you try to gain
possession that by pushing the other guy
over it oh there it is all right sweet
see to a circle shoot it circle shoot
yeah
wait so okay so you push it behind you
you push them off aha you get knocked
out which is all behind you yeah and
then two guys come and fight oh look at
that move
totally random by the way my guys just
on the ground oh no hands all this press
is more like that yeah yeah it was like
it's been okay Jermaine Jermaine eight
plus hair games Jermaine adult donate a
thousand bucks and you send me a bag of
your pubic hair so I could finally have
a beard like yours wait do we wait
Psychopaths like that I don't know you
know what time though I did try to sell
my beard on after the rush I we had a
Jason Shlomi are there are preachers and
I shaved off our beards and somebody
bought it for $80 that's so I would 100
cents sell my pubic hair for a G yeah
absolutely
my wife is dying for me to mean cheat it
down yeah grows back I got bags in my
yeah I got bags a bike I got bags of
pubic hair wait for the for sale people
I got planes backed up on the runway
with people if you have a hyper specific
fetish in it don't kick it out of bounds
let's go dude let's get it why guys saw
that Jemaine let's go long cost
Henner I will say this game is fun
because there's a lot of stuff that you
don't automatically which I appreciate
it looks sharp as hell to consider what
do you think oh whoops
did stop what if you say Gandalf you
will make my day aim higher oh [ __ ] get
there look at that there Lane did
nothing past
I don't think r2 is sprint it's really
weird the way let's all slide how do you
switch guys there it is there it is oh
come on that's a penalty
bet on better everyone plea on the
American team please get up
oh no no what did he shooting alright so
we don't know how to shoot yet I still
think it's circle right there portal or
whatever we'll call him
what is that did something happen there
disappointing 45 minutes certainly for
those from home while watching am i a
Star Wars or Star Trek for you well
interesting data ask me yes I am I
believe it or not a Star Wars fan and as
a matter of fact when I was younger I
thought you could only be one I did
eight have no like I have not watched
any start really yeah which is crazy
considering how much you've known I've
seen the movies I've seen know I've seen
one movie they want the whale sounds and
I barely remember to and I know I know
what about the TJ Abrams movie the JJ
Abrams movies I did see but I don't
count yeah well I don't think a lot of
people yeah that would be like saying
I'm a huge Star Wars fan I saw at
Phantom Menace Yeah right exactly I
cannot [ __ ] wait for the new Star
well it's gonna be awesome
have you are you guy who watches
previews yes but only previews I won't
do any reading about Star okay you don't
do any spoilers I'm not the only
information I have about Star Wars is
the ball droid is a practical effect and
whatever information was in the trailer
so no I don't wait the ball point is a
practical effect yeah so apparently
LucasArts this is how you know George
Lucas at least or of Disney or whoever
is super loaded they could not figure
out a way to design the ball droid to
look good
in my see visual effects and CG so they
just invented that they instead took the
money we're like let's just invent the
technology to make it work and now it
works how does it work it's like a prac
the ball rolls and there's like some
sort of like slight airlift that keeps
that little yarmulke part what's moving
around yet it's insane
the Robo yarmulke the Robo hooker come
on all right I'm just gonna oh it's hula
hoop okay and I'm just gonna keep just
shooting all right this you know what
when the announcers were disappointed
and it's bad what a game can't really
come up with highlights yeah he's like
we are we're trying like the announcers
job is to make the sport seem more
exciting they're not even like they're
just like they're like honestly this
[ __ ] is so boring we're sorry
like if the commentators end of half by
apologizing we're sorry you even tried
to get soccer a chance
I'm just joining us Jon Gabrus from wild
it out and joking office here and he's
going for a big nobody let's take the
time to get our players up there boys
the way I have some questions about wild
layout so and about improv on TV in
general sure is there do you feel a lot
of pride on him from Holly be better
I've been doing it for a long time
unfortunately a long time no no
pretensions yeah over ten years I've
been working with a braces for gate
theater that's various who's your 101
teacher you my 101 teacher was a man
named George Bo Decker who is but my
level 2 teachers someone everyone more
people I know Paul she oh he was my
level 2 teacher that's really funny
that's awesome do you take classes in
New York I did yeah back in like 2002
all right I'm just shooting I'm shooting
I'm assuming isn't it whoa yeah I give
you a corner kick yeah I'm assuming if
you work on Conan you may have lived in
Newburgh yes you're very recent hire so
so when you so what's the audition
process like to be on that chef for a
while now it was actually really
interesting when he show I showed up to
the MTV building where they were having
I saw the a cream-colored Lamborghini
parked out that was Nick Cannon and then
I just went in there and played improv
games and played different wild out
games with it just I'll tell you what
like I get a lot of guff first
things like this but the wild out
audition room looks nothing like the UH
Prestonsburg a politician yeah I walked
in on a room full of people that look
like YouTube rappers of various styles
that's playing big booty whereas if you
don't like chibi class it's like a bunch
of hot young wannabe models and like
this at the wild out auditions was a
bunch of [ __ ] like I was like one of
the three white people there oh my god
leaned into that and then so so you can
you play a bunch of didn't match up with
different people or yeah they mention
having two people and and I think like
they just had different groups go up a
lot of wild out is singing and dancing
which is not my strong suit but
apparently I brought enough humor that
that was okay overpower it also it also
helped that I was already sort of MTV to
channel I got like a little bit of a
pass you know he could guest star
because he's from guy code and right
wait no I did but MTV's cool like that
you know they keep it in the family if
someone if they like somebody though
they'll get them on more shows and stuff
you know what I need to figure out this
[ __ ] game I'm only doing this cuz as
I get better yes I'm learning I'm
learning that I'm actually way more
competitive than I thought I did because
now I'm like oh yeah it's funny Aaron
we've got a smithy [ __ ] questions I
want to win I do it's kind of cool like
the thing I love is like improv I mean
since you know since whatever like the
early two-thousands is really exploded
because it was it's so weird to think
that there was a time where like improv
was barely seen or even known about
right I get I still can't articulate to
my mom what I do rush what I spend most
of my nights doing right but other
people now understand it if I say UCB
people know what that means people I'm a
friend at UCB like oh who is it they're
like she performs Saturdays at 2:00 in
the I think your friend takes classes
performs like you know her I'm like
alright so just you know there's like at
any given moment 500
yeah and they just opened a whole new
center of it yeah there's a whole nother
theater UCB sunset on sunset just east
of Western but now that means nothing to
the Twitter audience yes happen live in
Los Angeles every Friday night at nine
o'clock you can see your [ __ ] up thing
which is my improv group I was gonna say
your fucked-up friend do you yeah well
that is what I can do but we have a show
called your fucked-up family where we
interview someone about how [ __ ] up
their family oh my god it's amazing who
seems based on that what's one of the
craziest stories you heard just Friday
night we had a dude who his mom and dad
both eventually came out of the closet
to them after getting a divorce and we
are both now games Wow yeah and his dad
was a gynecologist both closeted gay
gynecologist is I mean if there's a job
that might I understand we're all born
in a certain way but if there's a job
that might make you switch to being gay
I'm going spending all day like that's
like we're gonna butcher and then
becoming vegan yeah that's great did
that God did both parents know did they
marry each other because no no I mean
maybe deep down inside right but they
came out at like different points in
their life and and I think my dad just
wasn't around who's invisible invisable
gynecologist that's a new heart what
there seems to be a circular so are you
dropping a hammer some people here is
that what people are saying yeah what
again what's getting people banned not
that we should give any attention
yeah like spammy or like offensive it's
like Spanish
here's a great deal yeah yeah if they're
offering the paper what are the great
deals
hey John it's me uncle I have a great
deal but for anybody watching like even
if you want to be like a writer or actor
and you don't really you're not even in
like the comedy world yeah improv is a
great tool I will I like kicking it off
oh no I will have been directly quoting
the same even if you want to be a lawyer
or a stock trader yeah I think at least
take the level one improv class because
it was fun and silly and I don't if you
can just be silly in a room full of
other adults it'll help you with
confidence for the restaurant yeah and
it really is ultimately like a
confidence builder which is great and be
able to think on your feet yeah you can
pretty much any any occupation except
what I worked at Kmart yeah yeah just
wait you're stalking fishing lures
playing on Conan's room now you've met
chlamydia sorry about ten years ago
maybe nine years ago I was on I was in a
sketch on Conan oh really
yeah oh my god doing what I was rejected
x-men character okay I was a character
called the bully and I came out and gave
Conan's old assistant so Laurie scowler
knows a dude who's like a metric stomach
yeah yeah yeah tiny little shout out
piece Tubbs yeah I gave him a wedgie
yeah and I think up and took you know
obviously up until a couple years ago I
was still getting like
eight to ten cents in the mailroom those
residual checks are amazing yeah he an
actor is a big deal when you get eight
cents in the mail yeah
See Mom I've made it yeah and it's like
you spend more gas driving to the bank
right it's like that it's the fifth time
they've shown in Argentina but it is
kind of cool it's like oh I guess the
system is working like there's so much
so much taking care of me yeah every
time I look up there's at least one
question who's like who's the lady with
the computer or whose laptop lady I
don't know you know girl of course has a
little bit of ADD immediate into it
right but lady has a different God yeah
who's the skirt with the computer three
first said you should be a movie star
bro have you ever would you I mean
obviously you probably like to be in
movies now I'm good you've been in here
I'd much rather be on Twitch how do you
been how do you been I've been in a
couple I mean I've had small parts in a
couple of movies in this movie
premiering at the LA Film Festival
called flock of dudes oh that's cool
have a small part and then a movie that
is premiering at the Seattle
International Film Festival name of the
league all fourth man out if you're into
drama DS about feet guys coming out of
the closet and they're blue collar
friends dealing with it and this is the
movie for you
oh I like it yeah awesome yeah and and
what did you learn from that experience
like Howard Howard Howard doing it how
we do in the movies different from I've
never done you do a very specific type
until you write do a very specific type
tells me where I just scream and move my
arms around what everybody's very free
yeah it's very loose for uh for like
movies you have to also be the same guy
all the time which is like something
I've never had to do like besides myself
the other
oh I did something nice the crazy thing
is to that if it's not an outright
comedy like it's sometimes you're not
supposed to Joker but like the thing I
learned on this movie set was oh you're
not always just supposed to joke around
but they were like actually gaber's can
you be quiet you know different mood we
may be like between takes yeah yeah yeah
turns out people wow this game is
neck-and-neck that's one way that's the
positive way to describe to untalented
these are our highlights it's just
people running at some point in the game
someone touched the ball wait what's
Golden Goal that's our first goal score
first goal win never we should play that
well yeah we should play out what you
play penalty kicks
Oh penalty because at least we'll get
shot well something like yeah maybe you
know what maybe we should apparently
gets it then we'll learn how to shoot
right right all right let's do some
penalty kicks I think you got a pick who
you want to play so me company got to do
it oh wait we're gonna do does anybody
know any good dog you just put them in
order
oh okay become such a part of World Cup
history they have decided so much the
definite we're getting a little closer
here I think I'm doing too much
all right on going why are you going
nice sit nice
here we go Bradley we're mad where am i
where am i oh that was not a terrible
kick though now look at the bottom right
corner you guys are terrible yeah yeah
[Applause]
by the way how Stoke to the goalies
we're like we're kicking it til the
other side I think it's maybe kicking a
hole or something
well I'll tell you what I think if you
need the directional bad you do a
stutter step okay this is a good one
Oh someone brings up a valid point I
might actually be better at playing
soccer than I am at playing oh nice Oh
hit the crossbar hits the crossbar bald
guys so mad the guy from Cash Cab so mad
he's my going man that's an app that's
DLC Ben Bailey is the goalie
well done just open up a comic book shop
any suggestions - as anything I should
have on my show oh god let's get stunts
good stuff everything by Brubaker frags
yes amazing you should have all of some
old Alan Moore trades
top ten okay top ten is one in Alan
Moore's more underrated trades big fan
of love top ten drunk Godzilla yes like
top ten is a world where everyone is a
superhero
yes but it's about the police station
yeah the police department made up of
superheroes of various powers yeah like
for example in top ten one of those
great jokes I remember is that a guy who
does like fire who can create fire with
his hands runs a hot dog right yeah any
like girls dog
and there's also yeah like Godzilla's
son gets super drunk right right I can
take a beer so it's like how do they
deal with that saga saga is great I
guess my one of my favorite cards
running I just read birthright which is
really cool and also an art and I
someone just recommended that to me and
old trades I love I mean you should
carry all the Clairemont classic x-men
classic and I mean if you want I guess I
just read all the old jim Starlin Adam
warlocks 200 crazy the ones written
under completely under the influence of
drugs some really good stuff in there
too
alright let's be just two really good
teams okay all right all right so just 2
5 stars
I think that's only gonna help us right
right yeah I'll be Brazil alright I'll
be uh I guess I'll I'll be England yeah
yeah four and a half stars that's four
and a half that's close enough
all right or should we do a pl let's do
a pl what's EPL that's the English
Premier League that should be overseas
real madrid oh there we go there we go
yeah which which is the guy did it yeah
an Arsenal Ronaldo
Ronaldo is I think is real Madrid
someone's gonna answer that the first
comic book I mentioned was called I
think he's you said everything about
Brubaker everything by fracture fracture
so Matt Fraction he does like sex
criminals he oh my god Casanova which is
Casanova is really good but also all
they're all the criminal books oh yeah
there's also great like sleepers a
really sleeper is so good that's so
these two guys Ed Brubaker is the writer
and Sean Phillips is the artist and they
do a lot of like crime big collaborate a
lot of crew crime stuff yeah and it's
really good very new and wire and
sleepers leave I'll be man you all right
wait so can you be like someone else
like one of the good teams Real Madrid
Chelsea
it could be Man United or they go that's
who I am
oh yeah that's your
I'll be Arsenal's oh wait no Chelsea's
better right all right here we go whoo
here we go Oh Rooney
I'm a Rooney Rudy Rudy Rudy you're an
[ __ ]
Rudy look at yellow I am you're going
yellow I'm gonna go blue perfect I think
do you think the new battlefront will be
bad due to no space battles story mode
and Conquest mode the answer to your
question killer Cody is but Star Wars
yes moving on all right hold on maybe we
can learn how to shoot right here all
right I think I think it's like it's
press and hold there we go it's it's
it's press when it's in the center like
and hold for power like yes okay ask
Gabrus if he needs any water I'm good
but that's a thank you I think that's a
shout-out I'm guessing because I'm
assuming the overlap of people who
listen to comedy that's live to age 15
Polk is a circle what's one of the
characters like I think is you I mean
your mind were so fast being an
improviser everybody and you have
billions your are learning characters
like the water guy just stuck with you
or your kind of like this guy would make
a good character at a show or me yeah
yeah it's just I'm actually not that
much of a character improviser either
but you know any New York accent because
that's all the actual like that's the
only real voice I could do his second
New York accent so like it's kind of a
cop-out
oh that count that I went from indice
but also uh you know you come across
things or more specifically you come
across people that you know like oh I'm
just doing
my grandpa oh yeah just limeys and
because he's a real a real person you
know your characters at least grounded
right that's clearly me um well whenever
I do like if I have to be a woman and
mentioned some specifics from like a
woman's life
so he's something that just came up
between me and my wife I'll be like I'm
running out of Anthropology candles I'm
smell good and and my wife will be in
the audience after shows your bag
Voluspa I just my muse
yeah when you've been with the same
woman for 12 years you don't have you're
like right by everything I know about
women cause well that's it's kind of
better you don't mention maybe specifics
yeah where so where did that go I used
to [ __ ] with yeah this excuse me where
the candle thing come from
Oh Joely staying in the shade I played I
played FIFA like way back in the day on
like FIFA 2002 or something like that
how do you shoot I'm so tired of not
getting any shots on go here we go
happen we go it's just Who am I again
Chelsea is just Chelsea's amazing
defense Oh am i holding once your shoot
you should probably just a Rudy Rooney
Ronnie all the kids like is the Jacko's
the dweebs Motorhead Simotas BOTS solid
I like that we can look at the chat here
on Twitch and get a good microcosmic yes
some people are like there's some
genuine interest questions some just
like you guys suck at FIFA you know then
a majority of like what is that girl's
name
you have answered me there's a woman on
him here I can see her right there what
buttons do I click to get it a topic
everyone please bed for [ __ ] sake
baths I'm video games here my mouse I'm
sure I have a grey haired guy in a fat
guy playing video games here in my house
that woman how do I get a bath I have a
laptop is that all she needs maybe you
should like by making house calls I can
offer to run the chatter isn't best do
not do that bad place without security
exactly do you guys your Boston accent
what is that wicked smart
that's I packed my can have it yeah hack
my cab have it yet are you a big
accident guy can you do that I cannot do
I just terrible I did a show the other
night at the use of Decatur called stone
seems was on April 20th 4:20 and the
show is comedians get super bacon and
that's hilarious
and me and my buddy John gemberling did
a scene from the end of commanding the
big fight between matrix oh my god and I
realized the moment we got on stage to
do the show that I just and I had been
like I picked the siege well guy on the
ones and twos yes Stephen Stephen is
telling me he saw that and I literally
just turned into George Lopez maybe I
know teaching Sean kind of buddy
terribly offensive Latino voice trying
to do Australia
with Lopez on it that's Curtis she's
perfect let off some steam oh my god
good shout-out to the last line fight
let off some steam Bennett awesome
remember when I said I would kill you
last triangle plus l1 this this might as
well be like when you have your cousin
up here like your little cousin already
just unplugged the control only it's to
unplug control yeah we're gonna watching
the game demo for 20 key press
who's my afraid favorite Avenger that's
a great question play who's your
favorite man oh great I mean I love the
Hulk I just love him and here's why I
love him because he just keeps getting
more just stronger like he's crazy right
right that matter he gets the circuits
and he just keeps getting stronger I
will say about those movies in general
though every character gets is oh I mean
I see what you're saying as he gets
madder he gets strong right right but in
the movies affect the characters like
are getting more and more powerful you
have been Americans like ripping logs
and now yeah yeah and he's like he went
from super soldier to like a legit like
contender right I like I think like I
remember like as a kid like The Secret
Wars - I think when they drop a mountain
range is holding the mountain range ah
so how are you doing that he's like just
hurry you know yeah what about you what
about you I gotta go with I gotta choose
Thor Thor is great and I like in the
comics I was never a big Avengers guys
always x-men before Avengers but in the
comics I'm not sure I may be Iron Man
but in the movies Oh God
Thor is so [ __ ] hot yeah he's so
good-looking
I rarely want to be a man as bad as I
was but funny have you seen a more
crisper baby oh my god also awesome
you've seen cabin in the woods right yes
which is super weird because you've got
70 cabin of the woods it's about it's a
by the way amazing great movie great
movie but he's like way tinier yet it
was blaze Skinner because it's before he
got Thor it was even though it's
released after the Avengers it was like
he's done five five or six years ago I
also heard that when he first showed up
for Thor he was like too muscular for
the uniform they had design oh look he's
arms yeah they were like this is gonna
be a problem
which is so hard right yeah yeah like
also Scarlett Johansson is one of the
best actresses were an amazing voice
Captain America is so good-looking shady
fridge I'll admit Chris Evans is he does
yeah more than anyone I'm using yeah
Thor when it comes to dudes I like my
guys long yeah there we go man buns and
broad shoulders it's my dream
there kid there yeah I never really read
a lot of Thor comic books but I know the
whole Asgard thing kind of threw me off
yeah the movie the Thor movies are it's
crazy that they make I mean it's awesome
it's a people watching yeah I'm a huge
fan I think one of the things I love
about comic books that people don't
realize you know recount what is it
they're movies but you can tell any
story with any budget so it's like you
get these whoa that is not a penalty
yeah you get these great weird stories
that you would just never be able to see
anywhere else right which is fantastic
what that goes brings me to I like this
theory about the Marvel movies I really
like is that comic book movie used to be
now it comes with movie can be something
that's more like daredevil and it's a
little toned down in tanta hands right
and or it can be something that is like
Avengers were tall space [ __ ] or
guardians of a yellow spaceship but then
I feel like Captain America the Civil
War whatever there's gonna be gritty and
not so intergalactic and stuff and uh
greed and I can't leave these are not
even the the first Captain America movie
is based in World War two right exactly
and Thor is basically a space it's like
a fantasy epic and guardians galaxy is
like a space as more and more come out
like I'm pretty sure the Black Panther
movie is not gonna be seen I want to see
these pretty heavily in Avengers 2 he's
very good yeah Andy Serkis would
probably be the bad guy cuz he starts
with one arm yeah yeah so we saw his
origin story did you see that little uh
Joss Whedon's mentioned that they have
that little like there's a little Easter
egg and all the second phase movies
someone's lost an arm whoa wait really
someone's lost an arm in an homage to
Empire whoa yeah if you think about it
Groot gets his arm cut off by Gamora
Bucky Larson loses his arm Winter
Soldier circuses character got his arm
that's insane made the thought that goes
into those movies it's so it makes me so
happy that because it's finally the
people in charge are the people who put
as much care into thinking about that
[ __ ] as the fans exactly and they know
that accuracy and like connectivity will
bring them money so absolutely and
that's good they needed to hear that
absolutely because everyone else was
just like whatever we just put comic
book we put all these counties and
looting people came yeah like if we give
it the care that they want they'll pay
justice London and like Sony soul kept
us old spider-man back to Marvel I
didn't hear that yeah so is that Wonder
Garfield in here I think that's why
they're gonna reboot it now because
spider-man can now Marvel that's insane
and Sony's like of course why not give
it to Marvel Marvel's everything they
touch is gold that is we still make some
money on it it's great I will say nebula
was the one who got her arms cut off
from guardians galaxy also true it is
weird that it is kind of weird to see
like Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch you
know like as we get crazier and crazier
the licensing does we like create these
weird issues of like double character
right and they they can't mention
magneto yeah or the fact that they're
even mutants yeah which is like but it's
so weird to choose those characters to
fight for well like they're not like I
mean I guess they're West Coast Avengers
oh great save no shot we did a shout on
gone we're just excited that we get
close yeah let's go let's go but these
spoilers if you're watching it [ __ ]
twitch on a monday we sort of watched it
like i was afraid to come on here
without having seen yes yes
you got to do your work and do work I
like someone saying that 20th Century
Fox needs to give up x-men or share
x-men with Marlowe bold but I think
x-men made is making too much money
x-men is doing too well and they're
learning they're learning how to make
x-men continuity work the way Avengers
continuity works exactly putting it on
because like even with I don't know if
you remember like when the first thing
leaked about Blaine yeah then JJ
immediately put out a tweet showing the
chested be like uh leaks or okay believe
you go I've got this lockdown or
something like now I feel like the
people in charge understand the culture
that they're right you know they know
yeah it feels good and dude just the
right things
let's do something let's feel like
pressing buttons harder is helping me I
honestly feel like nothing can help me
now
I don't know what's going on in God's
hands now yeah I still have not figured
out how to run and I think our tuition
makes your character run near you
oh that's the run weird but all right
I'm just gonna rely on you missing
defense this is it by the way I just
love sliding gonna throw my body into
the path take the shot oh no no no no
here we go back it up sorry oh that is
such a classic rookie move just jam
everybody that doesn't go your way
magic hate sometimes it works what was
the triangle what's what was the
thinking in fact everyone in triangle I
think pops it up oh oh I see oh look at
that
sometimes a one inch rise critics
oh yeah I love the little billboards you
see that there they put out little tiny
billboards aside like ant size
billboards just so cool that is so cool
I was not excited about ant-man when I
saw the first trailer yeah but now the
most recent trailer which has like a
couple of jokes and makes sense since
you put Paul Rudd as him yeah like I'm
now excited for the movie I am except I
think it's good to be good I'm kind of I
love I have to say like I really love
the guardians of the galaxy like ant-man
like I love the kind of secondary
character movies because I yeah I'm very
curious like Inhumans and yeah anther
and then we're not even talking about
the Netflix or whole universe I know
exaggerated 'evil dude we have Luke Cage
gonna get so awesome so awesome
I hope Luke Cage is like a straight-up
like a classic station no he's but it's
gonna be it's got to be current though
right because they're gonna eventually
make defender yes ma'am I love that you
can just jump to the conclusion that
you're if a dude you're recording twitch
video games with you can talk about you
can just casually say defenders think
it's crazies like that I understand is I
mean again like and Cumberbatch's just
dr. strange right yeah yeah that's gonna
be fantastic yeah I'm interested but
again like I love the fact that in
secondary characters because they can
have more fun cuz it's not so one thing
I didn't like about the Avengers we knew
they had a lot of shoe leather a lot of
business oh my god there was a lot of
business to get done like there is so
much they're literally like alright
let's all split off and get all our
secondary yeah just from our movies are
no quick it's like check check check
miss Hill
[Music]
they yeah so he was supposed to be in it
and he would have fit perfectly in that
lay bed yes right
I'm shocked he was it it must have been
like some scary I think though they shot
it too I heard I was oh really
yeah but I wonder I wonder like that's
weird and we only have Ironman for three
more movies or we only have our DJ for
three more money so yeah he's doing the
Civil War and then the two Avengers part
three but it quite so I wanted to really
really you could just never give me
enough of these movies I had never after
I think infinity after the affinity
Gollop there was the thing where was
that a Morlock and it was with all the
twins and evil twins right right it was
that infinity was that infinity ward's
wars my Infinite Crisis yeah yeah yeah
but that was like a man I mean Jesus guy
I wish I knew how to do quarter kicks
because this is usually good you set
peace tactics korban 10:25 you excited
with the live-action Zelda series on
Netflix I didn't hear about it I have
not heard of that but yeah I'm excited I
am now [ __ ] yet no how did you hit how
did you do header I don't know also
we're not talking about an Avengers to
the end but James Spader is so good and
he's just playing himself he's Spader
he's just playing like Robert Downey jr.
playing himself
yeah he's just doing this again well
that's what a cool thing I gotta say
like talking about listen to fans you
know when they kind of rebooted stuff
for The Ultimates in the comic books you
know like they basically made Sam
Jackson yeah they've modeled the
[Applause]
and same thing with Robert ing I mean
they made him look just like so it's
kind of like it's cool than then like
movie makers are like oh let's take
these yeah I also feel like there is
going to be we're gonna see some of that
continuity in that retconning going the
other way where in comics they're gonna
try to like Guido who maybe didn't have
such as from comics bar Joe planer
they're gonna I'm sure what's the what's
the Jessica Jones yeah doesn't show
Jessica Jones comics oh my god you
practice this yes she got me talking
about comic books lull them into Rudie
Rudie
man pardon my french but you're an
[ __ ] beast of rock salt drugs one of
my favorite vendors villains so his
stoked yeah Ultron's incredible super
fun and Paul Bettany was awesome his
visions so awesome it's a big big old
grizzly bear saying and he was so good
and he looked good a little bit mazing
graphics look awesome yeah so what it
was that like a weird like I mean I had
to be like CG right yeah I don't wanna
be like whatever the avatar dots on the
face yes you happen along yeah it's
definitely gone falls on the face that's
the thing is like kudos to the actors
because there's so much green screening
and like the big stuff like
figure that out I do love that and one
thing I was upset about no like I love
the schwarmann right I thought that
would I can't believe I saw the movie at
midnight on Thursday yeah so for me to
stay after the credits was straight up
like 2:40 in the oh my god they didn't
have anything except for that spoiler
whatever the little I won't even say it
just in case yeah but that little thing
was not enough for me I know about that
yeah everybody gets the supposed to be
exciting cuz we're seeing something for
the first time officially bright but not
to me um I thought [ __ ] spoilers you
know people over here know that was a
really good shot that was a really good
shot alright I'm starting to get nervous
now I think I might understand how to
play gay first company hard coming hard
I thought the only thing that would have
made Avengers 2 perfect in my mind is
the moment when they sort of intro the
West Coast guys yes I guess this is our
team whenever it's it's know what
they're good or they work hard or
whatever yeah I would love it if there
was just one wildcard person that also
if I just wonder man was all something
some kind of weird yeah could have been
her what yeah exactly just like expected
I got a [ __ ] woman in like a leopard
print outfit they're like because we all
came in I think this is so cool if they
would have just had one person that
previously set up that would have been
[ __ ] awesome I know they did kind of
bummed me out that they were like they
show like they'll be scheduled all the
movies thanks I'm like oh well now look
for fans and you also now you'll that
also kind of teases what yeah after
credits things are gonna be every time -
now it's kind of like because like
you're gonna they're gonna have to set
up what kinda they're gonna to set up
all that [ __ ] now let's talk this is
gonna depress me but Superman versus
Batman I don't know man I think you see
where Dee
press it's depressing it doesn't feel
that strong but I also feel like I feel
like we can put a little confidence in
DC I'm hoping that I'm hoping that
because they're clearly going green
the Suicide Squad revealed all that
stuff I'm hoping that that is just what
their got isn't it a little depressing
to watch especially after Dark Knight
Returns so dark that returns as a comic
book work that is 50 yeah and he comes
back to fight crime and then the end at
the end it's like cuz you know Bruce and
and Clark are friends right and then
they're forced to fight each other
because of circumstances beyond their
control which is awesome which which is
the Bailey versus Dark Knight which is
the comic right yes exactly so they're
not I know
god damn I gotta come back but so is you
are kind of getting competitive I like
rugby rugby bring it I'm always
competitive and unfortunately I want to
act cool but I can never do it should we
play a little bit more as MLS teams all
right yeah I'll be a Lee galaxy all
right I wonder if this is gonna have
Beckham it might all right the only
match I've ever seen live in the
Pasadena the Rose Bowl and I saw Beckham
score a free kick oh that's what I mean
that's his amazing yes I didn't deserve
it but that's one thing that I loved
about that comic is that their friend
like that's the other thing is that
they're friends and I feel like they're
gonna have to flip it cuz they're
they're setting up they want Justice
League
yes yes what is this I think this is
dribbling practice oh my god alright
let's just play you know we mocked it
but we should have taken it yeah we're
like we got this cut to us not having
New York I think the DC movies look more
realistic okay Kiwi Depp how did you see
the Batman see this is what would
actually happen if an alien
another planet came down possibly so
it's more realistic so that if an alien
landed in actual America we would send a
billionaire to take him out Becca -
Messi I will say I don't watch a lot of
soccer but I do watch a lot of soccer
highlights on YouTube because daddy
you can watch 20 minutes just gonna
flash yeah the crazy boys right and and
since there's one or two per game you
just pretty much covered all of
somebody's career in ten minutes
[Applause]
I want to take a take a take a moment
right now just for the people watching
or at work whatever they're blowing you
know people security guards used-car
stores are currently watch this on their
phones this is literally what you do for
a living yeah so continue to terrible no
I mean continue to dream kids this is
the kind of [ __ ] like these are our jobs
yes we've done all right and you get to
be on TV which is even better yeah yeah
pays well it's really easy once it's
happening you literally I saw you
fifteen years to get to where you
literally got to make fun of Mellie to
his face yeah it's incredible that's
really exciting to me to be fair and
especially when it comes to rappers they
have to be from 10 years ago funny they
know who they are so that's very helpful
in Milan out to have Nellie on there
because that's like the rapper I
remember listening to when I was right
like you know like this new season has
gage loaf on it or real Strummer
Raees oh yeah drummers backwards like
race murder so whatever they've got and
I gots like I didn't know say these
[ __ ] yes Reverend and I was like how
the [ __ ] am I supposed to be one of
these dude yeah we did also have ice JJ
fresh you know singers on top do you get
surfer it would have to be someone very
specific for me to get starstruck
specific house like I met a lot of
celebrities but I would have to meet
celebrities that mean a lot to me
personally I'm starstruck like
I met Adam McKay director my favorite
movie Step Brothers and he is not a
celebrity like a recognizable slippery
but for me that was a huge moment I have
a hard time and being around the UCB and
performing an ass cat and doing a lot of
these explain what a status a scab is a
weekly show it used to be a sort of
their flagship show in LA it's on
Saturday nights of Sunday nights in New
York what's on Sunday nights and because
of that I've been afforded the
opportunity to meet a lot of comedians
and comic actors and comic writers that
I look up to big time they Peter Scolari
and stuff like that like really fun
which would normally be starstruck but
you get used to it or at least you
learned to act like you seem like a
[ __ ] dick and I worked on I was a
played one of the writers that never
spoke on 30 rock Oh like early on in my
comedy career I spent a lot of time
around people who I idolized
Caskey tracing them in their jaw being a
nobody around them and just kind of
talking them normally me teaches you how
to act that's not just kids that get
starstruck out of your system how the
only thing that would have killed me
that was I I could not go in the day
that Michael Keaton was guest on Michael
Keaton Kurt Russell Val Kilmer Seagal
Van Damme these are people that if I met
I would be stars there we go her boss
your boss Conan had I not previously met
him doing a bit a long time ago I think
that's easily a guy I guess my something
starstruck around Oh get out of it
that's amazing
wait so how is the 30 rock set like
hanging out so cool it's so cool
everyone there is literally the best
people at all of their jobs from the
kaepa from the craft services person to
the camera person to the writers the
directors everyone is like literally the
best New York talent and because Tina is
behind it all and
all the other people that work on the
show all her genius friends the show is
just everything is funny
Scott add and Michael Scott Adsit
Tracy Morgan he's been in a bunch of
great movies and yeah whenever he comes
on set Alec Baldwin's the type of person
that when you meet in person you realize
that movie stars are different than
really Wow he is so magnetic like you
like him drown in his eyes he also makes
like he's got very dangerous eyes what
you're saying he's got Medusa solo
dangerous eyes and also the man is a
true Titan like size-wise will is
enormous
no backslide tag he's a big dude with a
thick gravelly voice oh my god
that's Craddock I didn't think Bolton
was that big that's crazy
yeah he's a big boy he's got a strong
deep voice and a little I'll here's a
little top here's a little set gossip
yeah there's nothing - nothing too
dangerous but you can tell when Alec
Baldwin was shooting that day because
they keep a set like ten degrees colder
than there was like one of his demands
tonight and now as an actor's been
working for a while at night as long as
a being but a B likes to keep it cold
but if I ever have the power he has why
do you think that is why do you think
cuz he's probably a sweater because he's
a big boy who has to wear a suit every
seizure so it's probably a bit of a
sweater and it gets uncomfortable or it
looks bad on camera he's I keep that
[ __ ] ice cold
that's so funny also keeps your awake I
feel like - yeah that's what I was gonna
say something I wonder if it's also a
thing of like that keeps everybody
caught up right now I'm in shorts and a
t-shirt and there's a family right on
all my arm I am a sweater also so I like
to keep it our studio is cold as
possible oh here we go would love to get
Aaron's thoughts in the recently
cancelled Silent Hill game
from Hebei Okajima oh man ah incredible
it's crazy did you know about that
no I don't so I know the name Kojima for
some rules right so he created metal
ghosts Metal Gear Solid and and he there
was this big thing we played actually
I'm here where they announced a really
cool playable trailer that there was
going to be a new Silent Hill game start
Norman Reeves that and he was going to
do it penally Abrams taking over the
service right awesome but then all of a
sudden and no one knows why although
it's probably money because that's
everything like he leaves the project
Kojima or Hajime Lisa project project is
cancelled Konami then takes themselves
off the American stock so everyone is
like it's like it's like an Abrams was
like all right Star Wars yeah oh yeah
shoot yeah give it a shot yeah yeah so
everyone is like like what the [ __ ] I'm
super bummed because like the I don't
know are you a fan uh yeah because the
game is this trailer came out it's
called PT for play of the trailer and
like they released it under shell
corporations and no one knew like oh
what's this like oh and then on that
shall we reveal at the end is Norman
Reedus like and it says silent hill's
and everyone's like freaking out oh
that's so cool so cool
it's so fun it's cute yeah the playable
trailers that still out there yeah yeah
and it might have taken yeah I would
imagine they would because they don't
ever get any more exciting and it was
super scary did you keep going through
this hallway over and over and things
are changing it's really free but anyway
so yeah so it's great I don't know I'm
really bummed right now the hills why
the heck are Americans playing European
football it's the what what do you what
answer can we possibly give you we're
being forced
yeah exactly actually sports played all
over the world yeah I love people
explaining to each other what soccer is
maybe check yeah like European not just
we have the only one it's literally the
most popular sport in the world
it's not called European football it's
just football American football is
American for baby soccer is football and
football is life yeah I don't want your
lives
John shoehorning in it have you ever met
van der people I've never met that is
that a guy were gonna be starstruck by I
would definitely I don't know but if I
met Scott Caan who plays tweeter yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I think I think Kurt Russell would
be my starstruck moment although if I
may if I meant Wayne if I meant Dwayne
the rock Johnson tonight
absolutely agree that guy he's sweeted
at me twice whoa
rid of all times doodoo out like a
pseudo famous friend being part you know
I was on something he was he wasn't
responding to me as so much as he was
responding to PJ still counts still or
roll out Chord Overstreet I'll take it
that's awesome yeah he's a dude his
Twitter so funny yeah reading his
Instagram or watching his Instagram is
the most like I'm like yeah it's like
3:30 in the morning only person in the
gym it popping it gonna gonna have eight
pounds of coffee they may call me crazy
they'll never call me lazy
are you kidding I'm worried about the
diary I have my way to go play video
games amid pizza roll eating I had too
much sausage when I'm watching Game of
Thrones now that's it you are you G of T
fan big time Oh or should I say ASL IFI
oh my god ice and fire yeah oh yes I've
been a lot something you don't know I
may not have the look but I guess now
that you've heard so much that I've
talked about I'm a die-hard fantasy oh
it's like my friend Dan Matthews a comic
quote sorry illustrator and artist got
me hooked on some advice and flyers way
back in the day I was reading I like
Forgotten Realms
RA Salvatore Wow my favorite fantasy
author artists like he wrote the Drizzt
books the Icewind Dale yeah so I was
reading those and my friend Dan Matthew
is a bit of a nerd too is like Oh Gabrus
have you read A Song of Ice and Fire I'm
like no what's that he goes oh they're
gonna make it into an HBO series
apparently it's really good I've got the
first book off Amazon and then at the
time I was teaching improv and I was
like I'm reading this fancy book the
woman's like we actually work in with
this with the publisher and she said and
get you all the other book get him to me
wasn't like early editions or anything
like that but I had um I left
like 40 pounds I could not wait to just
get back to my party so what is your
opinion then of the fact that the show
is gonna finish before the buzzer done I
think the show is already going off the
books I was really on I don't because I
haven't read the later but I read the
first three read weddings in three right
yes yeah so I read the first three yeah
but I've now read five and they are a
little it's the storylines are at least
progressing in a different rate - we're
in book five and some of the storylines
a book people are different okay yeah
yeah yeah like Jamie comes back way
before you show yeah Jamie this this
whole mission to Doran is not in the
books whoa that's crazy yeah yeah I know
it but I don't know like what it could
what constitutes spoilers with something
with books that's been out for a couple
yeah spoilers stream you just get it but
I also I also now know that what I know
doesn't matter right they're off the
books yeah Dinklage doesn't go straight
to marine you know he's gonna hold but
do you think they'll actually like kill
people off I think so
Wow they already have killed someone who
doesn't die in the books whoa crazy oh
my god and yet in your fights you're
telling a purist oh no I have the books
I'll read them again right down at me
let me it doesn't anger you it says it
does angry now they're just two
different it's better now we don't have
to wait for george RR martin to finish a
book it should and i think also you know
Benioff and Weiss have demonstrated some
attitude what they're doing right I gain
their trust yeah
like if Joss Whedon was like or the
Russo brothers were like we're gonna go
a little bit off Marvel continuity I'd
be like I took stories
[Applause]
this look Tiger in there why is that guy
in the green always sweaty is that you
or me yeah I'm always sweaty me too yeah
except for today because I have all the
time a glandular issue if you want to
severe nerves this is so I'm certified
so terrified to lose to gamers again yes
series I gotta win one man come on she's
really coming to your own house
everything in Mario boys what games are
you playing personally right now that
you really enjoyed it yes I'm in between
games now I'm trying out a couple an
undertaking I'll tell you right now I'm
deep in bastian bastian don't know it
it's I got it at ps4 I downloaded it off
the old I think it was for PC and then
they they kind of I think so but it's
great it's like it's a little cartoony
but it's really fun it's kind of like a
hack and slash but it's like it's got
basically I don't know it sounds exactly
Ron Perlman as like a narrator through
the whole thing is like it's like a
world after the calamity has ended it
ended the next place there's thing
called the calamity would you this is
it's a little post-apocalyptic but very
cartoony there's all these cool
animals and stuff around you just gonna
just kill everything that's awesome I'm
splitting time right now between sunset
overdrive and watched also it's not
really loving I mean I like something
overdrive more the gameplay I'm like
topping out it's kind of a it's a lot I
feel like it's almost exhausted yeah
yeah but I haven't I haven't been as
happy since OH
Skyrim is amazed and and it's right it's
made for me because you know it's that's
my magic sword and sorcery but more
importantly no online component so I can
like come back and play you know leave
come back like I love I hate having to
be on somebody else's schedule it's like
dude come on man stop making gloves like
I want to I want to just be like jamming
on my leatherworking and I guess stone
just [ __ ] and then wander over to the
living room Totino's and then realize
and come back and then there's like a
dog barking and I don't have to worry
about that yeah that game is really fun
yeah there's a great I don't have you
like zombies for this game called state
of decay which is super fun and they
just relaunched it for Xbox one one of
the scariest games I've ever played
oh my god get up there I'm not scary
come on guys good something going oh
[Applause]
today indicates really fun it's
basically zombies
alright zombie intercept and but it's
kind of like GTA but with zombies so
it's open-world
alright you find these other survivors
you have to start a base so a lot of it
is like resource management usually you
have to fight you have to feed your
people every day or they'll start dying
which is crazy and it's it's just really
scary because the zombies you can't if
there's a big mob of them you can't
really do anything so it's a lot of like
hiding in houses while they like go by
and just pray they don't hear you yeah
it's just like there's so many shots
press triangle - yeah right it's just
like literally it's like this and
there's like outside the street really
dying light is better die lights fun but
dying light gets very repetitive die and
like it for you but you stop playing it
right oh you picked it back up alright I
stopped playing exciting just got very
repetitive in the missions and stuff I
tried playing I try playing always that
a fantasy game where it switches into
like a mode where like a strategy mode
you can do it in the battle it just came
out not too long
dragon blood nope Oh Oh Dragonborn no no
it's not dragon board we played with
favorites tuner age each of em huh no no
Dragon Age dragon get it we did it guys
we did it
dragon age we did it yeah we gotta
remember Freddie Prinze jr. yeah he he
came on yeah he came out and play with
us for 90 minutes we had I think the
developers know I was on sighs yeah
whatever
tell it to the judge is nagging me man
get out here hey folks transistor
apparently is another game from the
developers of fashion oh no oh I'll
check it out that's awesome yes super
tight it's really that's very stylized
it's very fun but also yeah there's so
for people who want to know there's a
clueless gamer coming out this week on
Thursday to be really exciting so watch
the show Thursday sweet sweet foods
gamer action that's really fun that'll
be it's gonna be it's a fun one to it
there's gonna be a lot of oh sorry I can
do this nope nope yes yes back mind get
you're playing these mind games cuz
you're part of it for is part of it you
know I'm positive get the power sir hey
take that goddamn shot William let's go
[Applause]
so running up the middle through a
thousand defenders it doesn't work okay
I'll come all those moves nope
you know let's get no don't stop run
don't stop running
come on
let's pass it to you okay Kay I have the
ball let's pass it back slide out of the
way
clean no I'll give my slide tackle game
down for sure but yeah I know this was
me cross dude but yeah bastions great
the K is great you know totally Red Dead
Redemption yeah there gave it man the
Kings I was really I fix flowers for
like hours flowers hours in that game I
have a little bit of a hard time with
sandbox games because I need like I
truly need a little Direction my
attention is just so ya know I cannot
manage to five opportunities
I'm coming for you I'm coming for it oh
no that was that was a that was a bona
fide shot what do you got what games
should John play yeah my xbox I have
Xbox one and I guess I could get them I
played all the blizzard games that's
like my foundation they're so hooked
great hook me up with some Xbox one game
I should be playing yeah I love fantasy
epics I don't like online gaming all too
much did you like fall out or no I
didn't play much fun it's very Skyrim s
but yeah GTA I play it and beep shadow
of Mordor it was my recent favorite
really good yeah it's really fun and
it's got the Arkham fight engine so oh
dude I love that I'm excited for the you
know our game for sure I saw the little
of just jump in 30 you just like I love
that too but a friend of mine pointed
out that that's a really fun part of the
game but then it gets it's like alright
figure out a way to get to the Joker's
answering machine well son you do like
like kind of like annoyingly
difficulties like your Batarang doesn't
work you're like oh what do i do I just
gonna listen to him send a fax price Far
Far Cry 4 IBT like
I enjoyed Far Cry 3 and 4 for sure Dark
Souls 2 blood-borne was really fun not
not so much fantasy as like for but
that's it I got red blood board has been
recommended to me before sunset
overdrive I am currently playing yeah
this summer
destiny destiny I don't like because of
like gonna playing online stuff I like
this
Mansa technically I haven't goodness
[Applause]
oh I've got ya playin watchdogs is
pretty fun watch sighs gotta get
repetitive
yeah it's confusing there's a lot of
like crazy like like the hacking stuff I
feel like I wish there was kind of more
to and I can't really do it right right
it is just get into the camera yeah
slash you can't plans Gabrus let's go is
that the [ __ ] that's on the phone but
it's like that's a classic NES game
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt I played a little
league of Legends that's a little too
much for Uncle Gabrus I play hearthstone
I am putting The Witcher games cuz those
are all fantasy there's no oh dude
Witcher that's what you should watch
some people are thrown out on yeah so
there's a new Witcher new winter is
coming out yeah Witcher Wild Hunt comes
out I think mid-may so it should be
coming out soon I think penalty kicks
let's do they just give me give me give
me one more penalty kick you got it one
more penalty kick on it game of war is
the Upton game game of DA Inquisition is
better than shadow of Mordor I played
both of those whoa yeah Shabbas Mordor
is just easier to get into yeah but
that's the whole thing where you can get
yeah it's really cool with the clans
let's go now we go let's break it that's
a pretty put it down the middle play wit
so which or two can I say should I play
with your - yeah yeah I don't know I
think my god see now we've gotten better
yeah path of Exile there are Witcher
books come on we're asking for video
game regular games yeah books that's
like saying oh you guys should try
exercise which is the great the bundles
in so we been get which or two on Xbox
Live
Oh wrong way yeah no need to play
Witcher - no yeah no need to play with
you - Oh yet to play with your three
moves Inc should I play with you - while
I wait for Witcher 3 just to play movie
[Applause]
dying light dial it's fun it's it's
first-person zombie action which is R
it's really intensive one I played a
little magic characters Animal Crossing
is supposed to be really good vibe heard
of an ejection seat why is that gig come
on camera and say why it's the best cute
as hell now you get to build a house you
get to it's the same type of [ __ ] like
making armor in Skyrim
oh alright alright so it's all making
gloves Skyrim just like inventory
management one thing one quick
I do love enchanting things like I'd be
like oh I'm gonna get like the ice bo we
like the flame like I would just tweak
that like forever I should just go back
to Skyrim yeah they got some do they got
some downloadable content and pyre line
they can there's one where you get to
build a house and everything oh yeah and
you just have a family yeah there's a it
like literally like you don't even fight
things I don't even like my real family
read Mitch man 11 is asking if we can
say his name no read Mitch man okay we
will not say your name alright we only
got five more minutes do you want to
play a five minute game sure you think
you can do it should we is there
something like should we just play skill
games
oh yeah we good yeah should we like
should we just do something go back I
feel like I got a wee nuts
I haven't beat you in a single thing
penalty to penalty kicks I lost James a
lot I need something alright get Skyrim
for PC it's kind of a PCI geometry -
you're playing jump tree wars or any of
that stuff
no no it's good yeah it's just use these
to Stu it's just basically like
asteroids but like on crack gay porn Oh
gay porn gay porn gay gay porn is not a
game but it is something enjoyable okay
horn I see what you're trying to get me
got it like 10 to 15
yeah like penis get it yeah gay porn
gay porn sounds like porn ready yeah
Titan Souls what's Titan souls it's time
so let me know when I'm gonna play it
titanfall is always kind of fun it was
it was it was really fun but again like
a multi downline multiplayer stuff I
just wanted like a one player i buy as a
quarry
i buy the Call of Duty games this is I'm
the anomaly I buy the Call of Duty games
play through the campaign
yeah then just sell them to online
gaming no cuz its people not like you
guys necessarily but whoever's shouting
gay pool right yeah people like you it's
people are going I want to smell laptop
lady's hair what's the shortest game we
can play or if we can play like a
two-minute game skill what skill moves
six minutes we were up wait four minutes
let's do it let's do it game speed we
could make a five and do the first half
here we go yeah there we go yeah
ball got a ball you feeling killing
floor
killing floor what kill zone I'm just
reading oh there's a boy there's a boss
like called the killer bro I only play
with the Saudi Nike
makes sense yeah well I was like I
didn't even do my research I shouldn't
do my research before you came only
sateen egg but here we go all right this
is my last chance I know I can do it I
got at least score a goal one goal is
all I ask
same teams different teams same teams
yeah all right here we go let's do it
Killzone was not cool Killzone was I
didn't like Killzone at all Aaron may
like Ori and the blind forest even
though it's a bit tough all right I'll
check it out if you can't score in ten
minutes five minutes will be eventful or
1886 and that sounds like ooh I like the
steam how do you feel about steampunk
what's your steampunk position uh you
know uh steampunk to me is a lot like I
like steampunk to me it is like Doctor
Who it's like it's not for me but okay
that's you can appreciate it out there
in the world yeah yeah just appreciate
it but it's like you do use on something
you mean someone who grew up going to
Renaissance Fairs and comic book and
comic book conventions or magic together
right in a minute it's like I never
understood the guy who had like I went
to the Renaissance Faire in full
Barbarian together this year so I'm not
even going I'm not that while it's
raining
roaring turtlenecks
or abs a surprisingly fun game for
stoners you just literally build star
star star basically coming hard do it
just got to score one goal
Oh gonna say it's not gonna get midfield
but passing from this team pastor right
- yeah I will send the friendliest
competitor I will send it to you all the
time and then I kick it out about this
ridiculous fun guy
I did actually see I feel like it might
have been an actual reference
it's I will say Renaissance Fairs the
turkey leg and - now the best the turkey
leg is real man
love that I am somewhere that those
turkey legs are actual Washington
Jennings but that might fool where EMU
Lane whoa yeah exactly I've heard that
the ones at Disneyland actually they
should advertise it as Jesus oh man what
if that gone in drop the mic
this rain is affecting my gameplay
um yeah I'm much more hurt for dry sigh
yeah yeah so get anything done oh wait
[Applause]
no come on what can we look forward to
the next season bobbing out we got some
great guests um we have I'm trying to
think of who I was there for there was
some really fun I Snoop Dogg would be on
the news oh there we go
which is pretty he's a snoop lion
anymore right now that he's back that
he's back to the d-o-double-g yeah he's
awesome we got a t-pain ty dolla sign
and a lot of great funny dudes and a lot
of new people that I had known before
ot Genesis yeah as in I love I'm in love
with the Coco video yeah so we had some
we have some good fun people in their
new season while now that's great that
should come back and early June I
believe yeah June 10th not to mention a
bunch of smoking hot new wild out girls
if that's your thing people seem to be
really into that I think so yeah people
are pro wild you know I mean like a few
episodes yeah check out joking off
Wednesday nights on MTV to is another
thing that MTV wants me to close that's
right me and my buddy Jordan Carlos I
think will be in another episode later
on
sort of like whose lines in anyway meets
tosh point-o yeah it's got a combination
of like eight sort of good ideas into
another okay stupid which was you
creating fake you guys creating like
fake online profiles from just a picture
right exactly
it's kind of taking social media yes
capitalizing on free comedic content
yeah that's great I'm sure they wouldn't
want me it's promoting it as such that's
the kind of crap people love these days
it's true a lot of bands let me throw it
it yes alright let's go to
[Applause]
before you know what I feel like I
deserve a few of those I've passed it to
you quite a bit don't hesitate not about
I agree I like the water around there
it's pretty exciting is it doing
anything the whales mr. girl walking it
makes me feel like I'm running real fast
take the shot
this should be a better pot I think this
said this week if you would like to
download the audio and not have to watch
this if you'd prefer to watch actual
footage of car crashes let us know he
was created have you seen that we go
here we go get in there no good dude did
you see
no I doing I gave you a porter kick here
that's alright I won't be able to
capitalize history history has shown us
anything cheap in game you ever heard of
NPR's tiny desk series where they do
little concerts like any desk no it's
great like a little acoustic concerts he
painted one and sang without without his
voice much and it was beautiful the guy
awesome he's got a good voice oh my god
it was amazing he's also t-pain is also
I mean he's like actually very funny I
believe it's even adults is actually
really nice it always surprises you
you're like are you going to assume
these guys have some bit of charisma
based on what they do for sure yeah
there's still good form yes yeah exactly
then you learn now they're actually
gonna solid sense of humor and stuff
like that
that's awesome Mustang
[Applause]
yeah I think that's because he's
fighting black home based on the smell
of the wild answer what is the only
rapper all the record labels watching
the titans of industry that somebody's
just king of the heart oh I've just been
listening to you guys and another that's
the way that's the way yeah they're not
even watching the soccer I understand
that this is brutal I would say that
this is my soccer such a great pub sport
though because yeah you know it's it's a
lot of it is not very exciting but it's
like when things get crazy a lot of
yelling unfortunately just we don't have
the ability to complete but one of us
does Gabrus hand so Blaine how'd you
how'd you lose all your weight misery a
lot of misery is it running broke up yep
broke up with an ex and then just
started eating chicken breasts and
vegetables like the time but was your
motivation spite in a way I like paint
self shelfing selfie okay cool no not
not hatred of someone else but select of
like self hate like dude
and did you tie your gain and weight to
the reason why you got reason why you
broke up or just no no if this is too
personal for Twitter no no no it was on
your tumblr I don't know if you have a
to portray that's true I used to have a
podcast called our JV soccer girls we
just talked about our terrible dating
history but but no no it wasn't it
wasn't because I think it was just like
low self confidence and it took that
breakup maybe put you in a bad mood and
what else was going exactly and still in
that bedroom
oh yeah oh sure Oh screw the cloud did
cloud doesn't lift cuz we lost the
weight a lot list his you know he gave
me and start dating someone else which
is that's not you can't put it on a
woman to get rid of your clown trip very
- no man is less likely to come clowns
present Oh trust that's what you had a
negative feedback but chicken egg baby
dinos pizza I just pulled out a piece
remember I was in the hospital right
it's this horrible thing I might own it
wrong right cross
gets a lot of torque exactly alright
well I think that'll do I think that'll
do is that 45 I think we're done I think
we're done no I guess you got to get
home and play more video I know exactly
exactly but thank you John for having me
on again joking off where's a Wednesday
nights at 11:00 and while they're not
just coming back June 10th on mtv2 and
follow this guy at Jon Gabrus on Twitter
please thank y'all for joining us we
will see you guys next week
see you later but starting in scorning
sorry we're so bad I mean I was
[Laughter]
you